First, to keep track of its position in the world, that's correct. All of our
entities in grids, need to know what position in the world they're at for a
number of reasons, like physics, collision and rendering. What about this, to
know when it's time to die? this is actually not required. Not all entities
have a concept of time, nor have a concept of death. For instance, landmine
entities only live on the map for about 30 seconds. As such, they need to know
how long they're staying around in life before they explode. Other entities
like these spawners, which will actually generate energy canisters and health
canisters, never die. So they have no concept of life or death. They stick
around until the map is unloaded. What about this one? To think or be able to
do something each tick? This one is definitely a requirement. The definition as
an entity as we've discussed before, is that you have a class which contains
some unique logic, that makes this entity different from all the other ones in
the world. The ability to think or have custom processing associated with an
entity, is critical to its definition. How about knowing what sounds to play?
this is a little vague. Some entities will need the ability to know, and play
sounds during events. For instance, when a rocket hits the wall, we would hope
that it plays its explosion sound
[SOUND].
The player for instance, may not need to know any sounds, because the
environment is making sounds on their behalf. And finally, what about the need
to post to your Google Plus Stream? this is more of wishful thinking on my
part, but in reality you shouldn't be coding in the ability to do HTTP requests
to each one of the entities in your game. Although, you should definitely check
out this place, I hear it's cool.